Okay,
many,
many more.
Hundreds of eggs are fertilized then
become humans.
Eggs get fertilized,
and by that I mean sperm get accepted by
over a lot,
but that's not all you need.
You have to attach to the uterine wall,
the inside of the,
of a womb,
a woman's womb.
But if you're going to hold that as a
standard,
that is to say,
if you're going to say when an egg is
fertilized,
it's therefore all has the same rights
as an individual,
then who are you going to?
Whom are you going to sue?
Whom are you going to imprison?
Every woman who's had a fertilized egg
pass through her,
every guy whose sperm is fertilized an
egg and then it didn't become a human of
all these people failed you.
Uh,
it's just reflection,
but deep scientific lack of
understanding and uh,
you,
the,
he will do literally,
apparently,
literally don't know what you're talking
about.
And so,
uh,
when it comes to women's rights with
respect to their reproduction,
I think you should leave it to women.
This is really a,
you cannot help but notice,
I mean,
I'm not the first guy to observe this.
You have a lot of men of European
descent passing these extraordinary laws
based on ignorance.
I'm sorry,
you guys,
I know it was written or your
interpretation of a book written five
century,
5,000 years ago,
50 centuries ago,
makes you think that when a man and a
woman have sexual intercourse,
they always have a baby that's wrong.
And so to pass laws based on that belief
is inconsistent with nature.
I mean,
it's hard not to get frustrated with
this.
Everybody,
uh,
and I know
it.
Nobody likes abortion.
Okay?
But you can't tell somebody what to do.
I mean,
she has rights over this,
especially if she doesn't like the guy
that got her pregnant.
She doesn't want anything to do with
your genes.
Get over it,
especially if you were raped and all
this.
So,
uh,
it's very frustrating on the,
on the outside,
on the other side,
uh,
we have so many more important things to
be dealing with.
We have so many more problems to
squander resources on this argument
based on bad science,
on just lack of understanding.
It's very frustrating.
You wouldn't know how big a human egg
was if it weren't for microscopes.
There weren't.
For scientists who are medical
researchers looking diligently.
You wouldn't know the process.
You wouldn't have that shot,
the famous shot or shots where the sperm
are bumping up against the egg.
You wouldn't have that without science.
So then to claim that you know,
the next step when you obviously don't,
it's trouble when you.
Okay,
let me do that again.
Let me just pull back.
At some point.
We have to respect the facts.
Recommending or insisting on abstinence
has been completely ineffective.
Just being objective here.
A closing abortion clinics,
closing,
uh,
not getting,
giving women access to birth control has
not been an effective way to lead to
healthier societies.
This,
I mean,
I think we all know that and I
understand that you have deeply held
beliefs and you want to and it really is
ultimately out of respect for people,
in this case,
your perception of unborn people.
I understand that,
but I really encourage you to look at
the facts,
and I know people are now critical of
the expression,
fact based,
but what's wrong with that?
So it's really encourage you to not tell
women what to do and not pursue these
laws that really are in nobody's best
interest.
Just really be objective about this.
We have other problems to solve.
Everybody,
come on,
let's work together.